citizens of the reject Nation will do a core
style citizens of the reject Nation get that
foreground we are here to do a movie reaction
for film when I was going through a list of
Coy's movies he hasn't seen and I was like
koi glad it's on your list because it's been
online we're gonna do a movie reaction to
Kung Fu Panda today baby and if this goes
well maybe we'll do the sequels who knows
it all depends on you guys so you know what
to do you gotta you know kapow that like button
is that racist doesn't matter this whole movie
maybe kapow like button also subscribe and
click the notification Bell if you want us
to see the next Kung Fu Panda movie follow
this man on the socials ain't that right koi
Sun at quite chandro that might be racist
well koi son and questionable we're just making
jokes people as always fully threats and watch
the long story sync up with your own copy
of Kung Fu Panda available for super sexy
rejects cover a whole bunch of stuff exclusively
over there speaking of our patreon most of
our videos uh feed through Vimeo over there
and uh recently we've got a crazy Hefty bill
from Vimeo for uh too much bandwidth so with
that in mind today's video sponsor fellow
Space Cadets it's time to blast off into the
final frontier with the help of today's video
sponsor Star Trek Fleet command today's video
sponsor I've been playing this game for the
last 90 minutes so you bet your buttocks I
am ready to talk about this game this free
to play open world MMO game puts you in the
captain's chair of your very own star base
on the front lines of a Star Trek universe
where you can construct fleets of your favorite
chips and recruit legendary officers to your
crew explore strange new worlds seek out new
life and civilizations and dominate the Galaxy
with your powerful Starships with the ability
to customize your Fleet and set your sights
on expanding your territory eliminating Rivals
explore important resources and exploring
New Frontiers this game is the perfect way
to Unleash Your Inner Kirk or Picard or data
or many of the other 100 characters you can
populate your Fleet with imagine commanding
alongside your favorite officers and living
out all your space exploration fantasies it's
enough to make a frenzy grin from ear to ear
I pulled that one so get beamed up reject
Nation join the millions of players already
exploring the Galaxy building their fleets
and competing in Space Battles click the link
in the description box or scan the QR code
right here on screen to download Star Trek
Fleet command today and boldly go where no
one has gone before I wanted to pun-centric
it a little bit you know
[Music]
hope this movie is as good as it's hyped up
to be Legend Tales of a legendary Warrior
whose kung fu skills were the stuff of Legend
[Laughter] s I think it will be
I see you like to chew you should chew on
my fist and then he spoke enough talk let's
fight cool he was so deadly in fact that his
enemies would go blind from overexposure to
pure awesomeness and attractive how can we
repay you there is no charge for awesomeness
or attractiveness that's what we say about
us every day way to steal Earth bit Jack Black
[Music] no one told me how cool this looks
oh my God these heroic heroes in all of China
the furious five bowed in respect to this
great Master we should hang out so pretty
and that's so get up you'll be late for work
what
that's the animation I'm familiar with all
right I was like does the whole movie I was
in the two
I used to know how to do that used to do it
without hands oh monkey mantis green viper
Tigress
a pig and a panda sorry Dad sorry it doesn't
make the noodles that cannot be his biological
father will we address it probably not I hope
they do adopted my geese I was dreaming about
uh noodles my son not finally having the noodle
dream
you are almost ready to be entrusted with
a secret ingredient of my secret ingredient
soup but Dad didn't you ever want to do something
else I thought about running away and learning
how to make tofu this is about chasing your
dreams koi like us being on YouTube that's
what we always wanted to do everything's been
accomplished by us I dreamed of Vimeo but
it was expensive for me
[Music]
they're real they are real yeah
well done students like Splinter mantis Master
Chief what it's masterway he wants to see
you you summoned me is something wrong
whoa I really like the teacher having weird
little like after effect Mudders like he always
looks exasperated detail why must something
be wrong for me to want to see my old friend
so nothing's wrong well I didn't say that
you think he's a villain he moves awfully
slowly I don't need a whisper we have microphones
I have had a vision will return
still that's the villain
we have to do something we can't just let
him march on the valley and take his revenge
your mind is like this water my friend when
it is agitated it becomes difficult to see
but if you allow it to set a word if I like
that metaphor the dragon scroll who is worthy
to be trusted with the secret to Limitless
power to become the Dragon Warrior I don't
know to the trade Palace one of the five is
gonna get the dragon scroll we've been waiting
a thousand years for this just foreign will
be there and you'll sell noodles to all of
them that's tough when your father's a goose
have to live in a shadow of a silly goose
so it goes very well done
[Applause]
it's like John mc4
[Music] you're a fat Panda whenever I choose
will not only bring peace to the valley but
also to you
I wonder if there's some riffs on like the
Chinese zodiac oh that'd be interesting 12
animals
[Music]
huh [Music]
oh need a thousand tongues
of Fire
foreign
[Music] a lot of pigs in this world wow yeah
two bunnies
oh [Music] this poor guy
ah he found him the Force Master Oogway will
now choose the Dragon Warrior
does one of the furious five think they're
about to be selected I think so because he
sensed it and then who else would be a thousand
years I'm going to see the
noodle dream I lied I don't dream about noodles
dad I love kung fu [Music]
H
go through the hole oh that's even better
foreign
[Music]
movie now how interesting Master are you pointing
at me him this is not a woke movie Tigress
has brought us a dragon warrior what what
what what what I like how his dad just got
in the door opens what
hey stop wait the
voice of that little was a hamster order
I'll say what is he you were about to pointed
tigers and that that thing fell in front of
her that was just an accident there are no
accidents is it a red panda the little guy
yeah I don't know Fox the internet's like
yeah we have failed you no if the panda has
not quit by morning then I will have failed
you he's gonna try to force the panda to quit
I don't trust him sabotage the band the destiny
of a thousand years this was a family wholesome
movie come on that mysterious creature we
can't name is Sir duplicitous double the guard
extra precautions may not be adequate you
doubt my prison's security Shifu does that
Ving Rhames yeah it sounds like it one way
in One Way Out one thousand guards and one
prisoner really building up this Baddie we
have Thanos level turnaround moment coming
I think because he visits he gets out fate
or they find an empty cage I'm just gonna
wait right here it's nothing to worry about
it's perfectly safe or Michael Clark Duncan
oh maybe I'm gonna tell Shifu he's got nothing
to worry about please go now well let's see
those eyes come on Hannibal lectric cat
oh now he's got a tool [Music]
oh [__] because he visited [Music]
I do appreciate all the Kung Fu tropes in
here okay cinematropes oh
I think the darker animation and the like
the exposure and contrast on them is very
striking the lighting's really cool the sword
of Heroes said to be so sharp you can cut
yourself just by looking ow [Music] the invisible
trident [Music] [Laughter] well done I
Jack Black is perfect I know I think his voice
work actually Blends really well said to contain
the souls of the entire ten shoe Army have
you finished sightseeing would you turn around
hey how's it going now how do you get five
minutes oh no you [__] what have you done
someone broke that but I'm gonna fix it I'll
I'll do you have some
you will never be the Dragon Warrior until
you have learned the secret of the Dragon
scroll who is this voice I can't pinpoint
it it's the whisper it's throwing me off
those are sensitive in
the flabby Parts belly [Music]
listen Oogway said that I was
you must know what happens when I flex my
pinky no this part is clean [Laughter] I love
animation tropes of the littlest people being
the most deadly and the pinky line was perfect
for building his whole power yeah
hmm sweet Diggity I love that a praying mantis
is one of the Mighty Warriors
the way they zero in on the unique way the
animals move is creative yeah you buy their
physicality because they're actually using
the anatomy of them yeah let's just start
at zero level zero there is no such thing
as level zero we use that for training children
he's got a Sinister way of talking just hit
it how's that
[Music] I thought he might have accidentally
mastered it but no oh
[Music] no oh how did I do there is now a
level zero perfect voice encouraging The Joy
Jack Black is having the sound he sounds like
Dustin Hoffman but does Dustin Hoffman do
voice over work sounds like evil does nothing
like James Wood or something Ed Harris I know
one of them's Jackie Chan and one of them
Seth Rogen I know that much we definitely
haven't heard Seth Rogue he's gonna be the
Mantis
[Music] I've had a long and rather disappointing
day so uh oh David Cross yes I'm such a big
fan outnumbered a thousand to one but you
didn't stop and then you just okay oh stop
breaking stuff we got big things tomorrow
all right you're awesome last thing I'm gonna
say okay to be shunned by Your Heroes I don't
know if Keanu was you don't belong in the
Jade Palace you're a disgrace to Kung Fu and
if you have any respect for who we are you
will be gone by morning damn that's a hot
tiger she's got that like goofy moving girl
thing yeah but I'm married I mean couldn't
touch the Tiger that's the first problem
you eat when you are upset mood
been there I mean I'm not like the five ah
maybe I should just quit and go back to making
noodles quit don't quit noodles don't noodles
I love this freaking Turtle he's the best
at his little shakes yeah there's a saying
yesterday history tomorrow's a mystery street
but today gift that is present he wrote The
Turtles dialogue is that from this movie
change society no [Music] [Applause]
[Music] that one feather that's all it took
oh no what's happening oh no oh my God Lord
of the Rings mobilize the Thousand rhinos
[Applause]
man you guys suck a hitting an idol object
oh my god oh you're helping him out [Music]
scared a path uh clever so Batman should have
done Dark Knight Rises archers [Music] that's
gorgeous that was awesome
all right he's threatening I'm worried [Music]
it's good
[Music]
it's like comic book panels the choreography
is so cool
wow they have to destroy this whole place
just to take him down it's the balrog
[Music]
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
no rhinos were harmed in the making of this
movie they were ready what if he's Jackie
Chan yeah great his talents are underrated
then fly back there and tell them the real
dragon warrior is coming home oh [__]
that's a machine oh 100 yeah yeah great transition
they got a great handle on the action it's
stunning he's quit you're not a real master
if you're this is your attitude man yeah it's
gonna make him better too what are you doing
here I thought I'd warm up a little you're
stuck stuck not laughs [Applause]
it's a flap I love it it takes years to develop
one's flexibility and years longer
foreign
[Music]
he
has flappable optimism [Laughter] fourth
opponent's weakness and make him suffer for
it oh yeah
holy crap don't worry master I will never
quit
[Music] hmm he's not gonna quit is he he's
not gonna quit bouncing tell you that yeah
who am I to judge a warrior based on his size
I mean look at me I'm over here Sam oh hung
you know Sama hungs huge guy huh there was
once a time when Master Shifu actually used
to smile before Tai Lung the first ever to
master the Thousand Scrolls of kung fu oh
my God Thailand's like Darth Vader oh he was
the chosen one yeah
he's Obi-Wan Robin all and he raised him as
his son I would get rid of that kid right
away that's it and when the boys showed talents
in kung fu trained him oh he made him the
murder he is today he wanted the dragon scroll
but Oogway saw darkness in his heart and refused
outraged Tai long laid waste to the valley
I see outrage in your heart no I don't I'm
gonna Slaughter everyone
[Music]
oh five point Palm technique Turtle style
Shifu loved Tai Lung like he had never loved
anyone before [Music] oh she can never get
his approval oh that's why she's such a pain
in the ass it's for Hope for and he's stuck
with you a big fat Panda who treats it like
a joke oh that is it my fault I accidentally
tweaked his facial nerve
he was such a good kid slightly predictable
landed though Zang I could use some good news
right now the panda will never fulfill his
Destiny nor you yours until you let go of
the illusion of control you could learn something
from this movie boy
nope I want to do things my way I am perfect
who just need to believe
oh he's gonna die I will try good
no I think they kill the turtles so and they
have to prove and believe and he becomes Master
see how it's happening it's happening right
now as we speak oh no he's getting force ghosted
you can't leave me oh what do we needed the
most
cherry blossom is real pretty though
ah returning to energy man that's my favorite
character he was great the turtle tortoise
either one both great I hope you like it wow
you're a really good cook I wish my mouth
was bigger Tigers you've got to try this that's
Jackie Chan okay Master Shifu
you'll never be the Dragon Warrior maybe someday
you will have your ears like mine that's good
ears of course it's Shifu what do you think
I'm doing
Thailand has escaped from prison and you're
acting like children Master Oogway will stop
him not anymore let us stop Tai Lung this
is what you've trained us for no you're not
even gonna talk about the dead turtle hope
you didn't love them trying to get rid of
you if you stayed yeah every time you threw
a brick at my head it hurts but it could never
hurt more than it did every day of my life
just being me oh that's really sad because
me could give me [Music]
China wow how are you gonna change this into
the Dragon Warrior
you don't look confident how I don't know
must be like one of those activation switches
within him yeah like learn one thing Powers
no like the yeah awaken something in him kind
of thing I like that shift in Conflict that's
really interesting because now they both want
the same thing with just dialogue this is
what you trained me for oh she just got done
solo
good team guys stopper we're not trying to
stop you what we're coming with you no you're
all gonna die
some great music transitions are so cool too
I got nipple chills my nipples got hardcore
I mean that happens to great music you gotta
feel it the music is also backed by some gray
scene worth there that's gonna um
hahaha
he's motivated by food oh the peach tree
genius
what they thought was as big as weakness with
his strength yeah this movie's not fat shaming
it's that emboldening that strengthening I
just thought you might be monkey he hides
his almond cookies on the top shelf
genius
don't tell a
monkey look at you yeah I know I disgust you
and yet you are 10 feet off the ground and
have done a perfect spread
there are no accidents you're damn right I
feel like you get cramps all the time though
if you have to be using food 20 minutes after
you swim come on yeah well you can't just
eat and fight someone this is the birthplace
of kung fu [Music] I see it do you want to
learn kung fu yeah and I am your master okay
[Music] don't cry I thought Jack Black would
be way more over the top of his voice So Perfect
it's actually like more sincere than I expected
[Music]
awesome bow reflexes it's actually Harkens
back to a lot of like old kung fu movies I've
seen the Montage or the specific moves the
way the Montage is going in the placement
of like using food as a motif oh I like that
it's a jagger chamber called Fearless hyena
I love a good Improvement Montage [Music]
look at him go look at him go muscle memory
learning
he's becoming the cool animation yeah I vowed
to train you and you have been trained you
are free to eat
hey
you are free to eat am I are you
Free Yourself
[Music]
yes yes that's what I thought they do I love
it
oh
no
oh come on you can beat him look how happy
he's becoming [Music] [Laughter]
I'm not hungry that type scene I've seen that's
definitely like Jackie Chan like Copland and
yeah Rumble in the Bronx era
cut it
oh you take him on one-on-one what is the
Dragon Warrior oh so that is his name love
how they gave Jackie Chan barely any lines
how creative so cool Dynamic 3D
[Applause]
oh wow so smart crane where are you
[Music]
pray mantis
there you go
this guy's ferocious [Applause] [Music] cool
[Music] ah that teamwork
yeah that was sick well they've slowed him
down which is nice the team Dynamic was so
cool there yeah
[Music] they did not slow him down at all
nope told you well oh no everything he just
murdered the whole team are they done no oh
Frozen paralyzed he could have killed didn't
he so you could come back here and strike
fear into our hearts but it won't work uh
it might it might I'm just one knee but you
will have the one thing that no one else does
dumplings [Music] oh get in the scroll [Music]
summon shenzhou
oh I love that that's fantastic a single cherry
blossom you will feel the universe in motion
around you wow can I punch through walls huh
Focus he's like Miss Marvel yeah Ernest Kamala
Khan energy it's blank what okay look no put
it on fire
Evacuate the valley what about you master
I will fight him what I can hold him off long
enough for everyone to escape defeat be doth
I'm very proud to have been your master don't
sell yourself one that you've got and you're
gonna die you can't go in thinking I'm going
to die it's going to become a Force ghost
[Music] good to have you back son I think
this Goose made it with a panda
vegetables classic structure man or do you
think the character is going to go back to
their where they were at the beginning but
no they don't they can't they've evolved they've
changed even if the world hasn't sometimes
I can't believe I'm actually your son Paula
I think it's time I told you something I should
have told you a long time ago it doesn't realize
he's adopted he's a panda the secret ingredient
of my secret ingredients
but nothing yeah he made it that is what's
on the scroll I was right to make something
special you just have to believe it's special
so the mcu's nothing depends who you ask which
part of the internet
oh essentially your dad you're punching in
the face you knew I was the Dragon Warrior
but when Oogway said otherwise what did you
do shark your shoulders nothing you were not
meant to be the Dragon Warrior who drove me
to train until my bones cracked who denied
me my destiny I like the dream dream parallel
with the dads
oh that was awesome amazing yes amazing give
me the scroll I would rather die
oh where are you wow [Music]
holy [__] tell me how proud you boo tell
me [Music] kamehame I like how there's a sense
of improvisation to the fighting yeah but
still style like they are very unique I have
always been proud of you and it was my pride
that Blinded Me I loved you too much to see
what you were becoming you could learn a lot
from this movie from him yeah loving something
too much can't see it's probably won't let
him see the message forest trees [Music] oh
you will never see that
[Music]
I am the Dragon Warrior Kim he's a panda do
you have a panda it's better you're bad you
want it come get it finally there you go oh
[Music] crush your instincts
everyone wow
[Music]
it's like drunken Warrior Twitter exactly
I was thinking like drunken masters kind of
fighting just the free flow chaos yeah
great everything is learned [Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the
camera work it's so gorgeous how old is this
movie yeah feelings could have come out like
recently three of them the power of the Dragon
scroll is mine
it's nothing there is no secret ingredient
it's just you [Music]
that was unhelpful oh he's too big he's too
big the anatomy
[Music]
very drunken mask
and the joy is why you have to have Jack Black
[Music] [Laughter]
I
worked sumo [Music]
he's dead you're just a big fat Panda I'm
not a big fat panda I'm the big fat Panda
yes you're bluffing Shifu didn't teach you
that nope I figured it out [Music] there's
like Jack Black says that I think is from
this is it unlike the other 1800s
[Music]
broth runs in his blood he saved the pigs
and the bunnies they get saved the pigs and
the bunnies this town is only full of pigs
and flies the occasional Goose [Applause]
Warrior is my son biologically there are no
other pandas in this town [Music] oh that's
hitting
the Lord still has like this shittiest stamina
there's no cardio
[Laughter]
I defeated Tai long you did why wow [Laughter]
it's still surprised wow you have brought
peace to this Valley and to me thank you you
can't die too everybody can't die they're
sequels
oh what is he really gonna die too no no
no no I am simply at peace
oh so um I should stop talking if you can
oh it's cute uh the dragon reflected in the
water oh I love that you wanna get something
to eat
hi yeah that was so good
all right see who everyone is
it is
did not hear it oh oh yes yes yes I remember
that now she has a warrior voice there it
is very obvious
Donkey Kong which I haven't seen yet Lucy
Lou Jackie Chan Herbert Shanghai Knights David
Cross very recognizable voice
Randall duck Kim oh yeah yeah James Hong that
one's driving me nuts was Michael Clarke Duncan
okay
17 line Jackie Chan he barely gave him Eddie
lines Jackie Chan watching for Jack like the
year of the monkey needed the respect I mean
it's the it's Jack chance so much inspirational
sure came from some like I know Jackie Chan
didn't really do too much like Kung Fu fantasy
right but like the basis of a lot but there's
a lot of yeah Hans Zimmer music it was super
cop not Copland but I was driving me crazy
this whole time super cops the movies I love
yeah the music was stunning I wonder who shot
it like cinematography by e I feel like there's
a time when they wouldn't credit the cinematographer
and animated movies because uh what's his
name deacons did the Arthur the art director
because deacons did Rango and that was before
this that's different they did a lot of mocap
for that oh that's true but the drains are
all very Deacon no there is there is like
cinematography involved and I feel like there
was a time where they wouldn't make that explicitly
clear and animation because it it was so visual
because yeah you gotta like direct this shits
too yeah like you built it and then
man that was a pretty film thanks to all these
folks
this song didn't make the Billboard top 100
like Mario's did Jack Black's a tracking artist
now it's amazing
oh is this Jack Black singing the cover oh
it is yeah I hear it now because he did that
song Peaches and he made the Billboard charts
that's Mario you'll know when you see Mario
Dan fogler man doing for a while when was
this Let Me Assume if there's a post credit
scene Kung Kyle Gas good I'm glad he got in
here Fu Panda Wayne Knight was the king boss
host credit scene I feel like there has to
be there is an after credit okay we will wait
it out that way the and we'll we'll talk in
the meantime we're gonna talk anyway uh so
I loved it hi opinion I I personally feel
I was a little worried at first well not the
very beginning the very beginning I was like
this is stop smackingly gorgeous and then
there was like a 10 minute window where I
was like is this for me and then it immediately
wasn't it stayed for me so a late First Act
a little bit of a pacing issue but then I
was I was struck from two and three yeah eventually
Broach is passed like this is just a kid's
movie yeah it got through it yeah like they
did that we have to make the kid movie like
set up and then they let us play yeah because
while like there's some funny moments in here
I mean there's a lot of jokes that are very
much obviously intentionally aimed at like
children and to be family friendly uh as it
ought to be you know like does sometimes I
feel like there's like certain animated movies
where the comedy is just like so clever yeah
so good and this doesn't quite go there for
me but the comedy's not the real star of this
movie the star of this movie is the animation
the action scenes and there was like just
enough funny moments for me to keep me engaged
but the movie is also where it's hard on the
sleeve the whole time like there is so much
heart with its characters throughout it had
more Ted lasso than a comedy for me it was
just like warm yeah there was a lot of just
like joy and it was a celebration of Joy Jack
Black was celebrating Joy the Victor was the
one that like fought with joy yeah and I was
surprised I really was surprised by how they
got all these celebrity performers in here
and a lot of the times when you hear celebrity
performers they're stiff and I'm more aware
of who the celebrity is agreed but their voices
really did match well for these animals that
they're playing especially Jack Black like
he was perfect for it and I thought I thought
Jack Black might just go in with being a little
like too over the top yeah like really just
like I'm gonna go crazy here with my voice
work um but he's like a voice actor it was
like a real performance great work yeah I
mean I agree the physicality of the animal
mixed with their fighting style and their
voice I think that's why this movie's so unique
is those Dynamics don't always land all three
like the casting was both physical and emotional
and it was the visual of the animal and I
feel like it put you in a universe in a really
unique way well I really thought that you
they usually could have just done kung fu
fight scenes or or just you know good kicks
and punches and flips sure but they really
thought about how does like a snake move how
does a tiger move how does how do they latch
on to things how does a monkey move and they
they and the animation so like kinetic throughout
yet it was still dazzling and they would constantly
use that within their choreography yeah of
how specifically these animals would move
and and enhance that height in it and I thought
that was like one of the smartest choices
they could have used so really how I would
say about like The Incredibles of like only
animation could pull off this with superhero
Powers they managed to do this so it's like
well we have animals so let's really lean
into how these animals would maneuver around
and then yeah like the teamwork I kept thinking
X-Men like how they would fight with their
strengths and coordination because they've
trained for 20 years yeah and then like especially
that bridge sequence I love the bridge that
might be my favorite scene in the film is
the bridge sequence where they're using the
animation medium and a really unique way mixed
with the animals mixed with like what we've
learned about their fighting style and then
the z-axis is just bananas like yeah it's
doing so much and I thought it was also a
clever play on the whole Chosen One motif
of how that's kind of just BS right yeah that
it's really just about belief in yourself
that oh and then the chosen one stuff tends
to come down to that but there still is a
Chosen One quality to it and this one literally
a mirror yeah this one was like your parents
aren't important right right thank you Ryan
Johnson
gotta tear down your Heroes and find the hero
within anyone could be a hero what was he
I think he's a red panda what kind of animal
is that what is the name of the Kung Fu Master
I don't know [Music] what kind of animal my
my phone is so messed up you ever get 10 minutes
into filming a reaction audiencing oh man
I'm starving oh my and then the movies about
food yeah I was struggling 10 minutes into
this movie I was like oh man I am so hungry
about the beat where he said he dreamed of
food I was like I'm actively dreaming of food
and I I love that too of how food is his coping
mechanism and he imagines it I lost a visual
and they didn't overdo that I was afraid once
we saw it once they do it like 10 times like
he'd become food and then be like all these
food like they didn't want to give us the
visualization it is a red panda yeah yeah
oh and that's beautiful because you're related
to pandas so I like that it's a red panda
s's Master as a father figure even though
it's a separate entity and he's a panda red
panda nicely done like that like that a lot
Interscope you know P Diddy and uh no that's
that's uh Bad Boy Records who's under scope
now I don't know I think Dre anyway good for
them great music all the great rap music in
this where's that post credit scene edited
on Avid nice ah and HP they gave credit to
as well which I've never seen Hewlett-Packard
gets them Lucas work this one Lucas
what a great transition set up the sequel
yeah I'm definitely gonna eat I'm so I might
go get dumplings
oh I love that beautiful oh I'm glad it wasn't
more I actually really like that it's a [__]
metaphorical beauty of the end instead of
being like a joke they should have set up
for the villain well Thanos is obviously the
post-post credit scene where the the snow
lever turns around and smiles at us because
he's collecting all the Infinity uh you know
dumplings unless you're making a snail oh
I hope this is the villain is a snail I hope
it's a turtle and there's a hair in the next
one was animals uh so I love the metaphors
of this what what did you uh what was your
biggest boy and you judged me and said I needed
to get something out of this I clearly was
missing uh because it's about me apparently
and I didn't get it either time you said it
which just made the joke I spent like 70 of
that movie judging myself going like what
am I doing I feel like the I feel like him
in the first half I was just messing around
but it made it so funny I was like what am
I not seeing in my Jedi masks Pride blinding
koi man that's like pride of what it's just
totally it worked yeah you're worthy man you
gotta just um you know you're good enough
dude I gotta just be more joyous in my I mean
I love how he eased into it with a relaxation
as well I think there's a sense of of overthinking
that the movie does uh talk about quite a
bit yeah you know especially that thing in
the beginning I forget what is the water rip
I've never heard that before you've never
heard that that's one of my favorite meditation
Concepts so uh a still water is the only way
you can see your reflection and the more you
overthink the more the ripples in the water
there are so when you look at Still Water
it allows you to be truth to the visuals so
like if a couple Rebels you can still discern
it but when you're upset and anxious it's
all ripples yeah so like rain metaphor throwing
Rock metaphor there's a lot of really cool
it helps my brain like cleanse you know take
some medication I think I mean that's the
trick yeah
that sounds like a lot of work I go to a river
no just go to the doctor take a lot of pills
take a bath yeah no I love the Stillness I
also love the spontaneity of like the split
like that was a really cool moment where it
was like great reveal he let himself such
a good reveal fantastic reveal yeah I I thought
like how he got into it in a relaxed way and
how they kept his fighting style with that
kind of drunken master fighting was great
it was like the kind of kung fu movies I grow
and I've kind of mentioned it a few times
on this channel there was okay so the arrow
in Jackie Chan blew up in the 90s um there
was also they weren't they hadn't made it
to the states yet but he was actually the
director of the movie Mr Nice have you seen
Mr Nice Guy with Jackie Chan okay uh you've
seen the Ip Man movies yes you have okay in
the second movie the big guy who he's I don't
know if he remembers like the the really overweight
guy who's like a Kung Fu Master maybe have
not seen the upman I'm realizing in real time
um I think I've just seen the poster a lot
of times I've seen that when I okay so Jackie
Chan he like he had some of his moves when
we came over here in the 90s and I came over
here like he had some of his films like Rumble
in the Bronx which was dubbed he was having
his movies come over dub before he came out
with rush hour which was American made and
my brother and I we became pretty obsessed
with like Jackie Chan movies that were actually
in Hong Kong so movies like uh Wheels On Wheels
Fearless hyena things that a lot of people
hadn't seen out here but they were like hard
VHS as you had before yeah and so I would
watch a lot of those and that's more of what
this was reminding me of so I grew up on that
there was like the umbl films and the Samo
hung movies and they grew up together and
samahan has done a lot of stuff in America
so far but basically um yeah those are the
kind of like Hong Kong influences and there's
like the Hong Kong fantasy kind of action
films and I've seen like a few of those uh
but those weren't really the thing I was more
like was the things that I feel more realistic
yeah because there's like that Hong Kong fan
it's like like a Crouching Tiger is a Hong
Kong fantasy um and this I thought was a great
melding of amalgamation of all those films
especially when it came to like the way how
he fought like a relaxed Warrior of that is
someone who's coming what I thought was impressive
about what they did with Poe was how he did
his fighting style reflected not a Stern type
of disciplinary Warrior it reflected him as
a character as a person and I thought they
really fleshed out who these characters are
through their physicalities as well you know
what I mean that's not meant by the the voice
acting masking matching the physicality matching
the animal like that's three layers that I
think immediately puts you in the world faster
than a lot of Animation because you're immediately
like oh this voice is familiar even though
I can't place it and it fits for the animal
which is a weird thing to think but I'm like
that's that animal's voice yeah he had a Carefree
fighting style yeah if anything he kind of
like that the whole thing about talking like
more water there's a version of this where
it's like oh he kind of Moves Like Water and
sometimes it's an allegory or a metaphor for
how they describe certain type of fighting
styles like you got to be fluid like water
under is a certain time yeah and I thought
that was amazing of how they did that because
he's fighting against the snow is it a snow
leopard that's the snow leopard who who they
they are very just you know because because
what I was saying about how it feels like
there's an improvisation to the fight I there
that's something that I think is under recognized
in fight scenes is how there is it's court
it's choreographed obviously it's choreography
but the whole point of like a great fight
is to not make it look like it's so rehearsed
right and they managed to do that here with
the animations were just very hard it's hundreds
of hours yeah yeah and they managed to make
it feel like they're they're improvising throughout
and a lot of times that does come into like
when the snow leopard gets hit by the fire
and dives into it and picks up the fires using
it you know I thought that was great and so
I to me this captured like the essence of
great fight scenes with beautiful imagery
we uh my family grew up with it was it was
a three Sylvester Stallone obviously what
age are we yeah uh we had a VHS that we were
recorded three movies off of like HBO or something
it was uh Rumble in the Bronx Legend the Drunken
Master and then something cop either super
cup super cup yeah so those were our three
big Jackie Chan's growing up and then as he
got to America like we I discovered more but
I remember like watching those three on the
loop and then next was Jet Li and then Tony
jaw and I remember specifically Jackie Chan
was fun and then gently it was like stiff
but like really precise lines of quippy and
then Tony drop was brutal uh so it was interesting
like to see the the uh popularity of kung
fu or martial arts changed through those artists
and I feel like I felt like the Jackie Chan
this felt way more like Jackie Chan because
of the fact of How It's like Poe is there's
there's a comedy he's not perfect he's getting
hit all the time which is Jack James and the
way he uses items around him is very Jackie
Chan um yeah the comedy leniency into his
fighting style felt very Jackie like there
is because like there's drunken master came
out here but a lot of people don't realize
that's that's actually a sequel oh um that
came out here and and I love that one the
sequel that came out here and the first one
he did was the was like I think I want to
say like 20 years prior um and that was the
film that made Jackie Chan super famous in
Hong Kong was the first one he did and that's
where he is being trained to become a drunken
fighter cool uh it's a spiritual sequel made
it here that's yeah and the seat that the
actual sequel then got dubbed and brought
over to the states cool yeah that's the one
that you're talking about the one with the
guy where he fights again yeah he kicks right
yeah yeah and like the that's all flow yeah
and so this one reminded me of that first
Drunken Master movie come on and then there's
the thing with the I mean that's kind of like
a common Kung Fu thing when they're fighting
with the food yeah but yeah there was in a
couple of like Jackie Chan I like that even
a couple of the moves were exactly the moves
earlier like there was a couple frames where
they changed the camera angle so you could
see that he was mirroring the moves that he
said he fought against earlier really enjoyed
that Master learner Master absorber yeah well
hopefully you guys like this I want to watch
the second one I don't I feel like they could
have utilized I hope in the sequel they use
the cast more because I'm really curious like
today because like Jackie Chan's just chilling
and he's around Jake yeah like like eight
lines and a lot of them were single words
what's going on does he like not like to be
on a sound booth because he's got action to
do it even like using Angelina Jolie and Seth
Rogue like all these famous people yeah he's
so unnecessary you guys come in uh Thursday
Friday that's enough that's it just check
in like they really use Jackie Chan um Ian
McShane and then and uh Dustin Hoff I now
remember one of my favorite press images of
all time is Angelina Jolie was pregnant and
and Jack Black was pushing out his gut and
they both have the same size oh really and
it's in front of all the uh the panda stuff
oh so it's the panda belly Jack Black belly
Angelina Jolie belly but I completely forgot
that image it's so good but I hope because
they went on tour around the world that they're
in the next one more I hope they use them
more because yeah they didn't see like David
Cross was kind of used in the David Cross
they each got a little section but each section
was shorter like I feel like they all got
their Shining Moment but like moment I mean
it makes for good trailers right like when
you stand for billing yeah exactly it's a
poster exactly it is a poster that's what
I meant for like trailers yeah and good billing
for Kevin Bacon because now we're all closer
because they were all together I mean I do
want to watch the next one I got a lot out
of that I It's tricky because the legend was
so big like I've heard about that movie for
years and I was really worried that I was
like because How to Train Your Dragon it's
one of the few anime movies that like to me
is timeless and perfect and I'd put this like
as something I'd love to show my kids as well
as adults like this is one of those that really
lands for all ages and demographic I mean
not to mention too that it also I mean I've
seen a pretty good amount of anime at this
point in my life now and so I think about
a lot of those and then uh there's even like
avatar The Last Airbender reference there's
a lot of like this this is just like influence
Bonanza yeah and in a way that manages to
not feel over convoluted and in fact I wish
it was kind of longer yeah see some of the
carrot the other characters and watch how
that was Dynamics keep it at the heart and
center of sifu is that was that just what
he's called who which one
but keep at the heart and Center Shifu and
I'm like how you point out in the reaction
when they they flip in the Dynamics of like
I need you to stay so I can train you I love
that that way and that was all through dialogue
I really like that you know in every movie
there has to be the conflict switch where
you have the unlikable uh trainer or Master
he has to find a reason to want and usually
it's like more cliche like there's usually
something that's like obligatory that it's
like well he's not really forgiving him but
this was just dialogue where they were both
fighting for the same thing from opposite
directions it really wasn't the way I like
that all right what would you give it out
of a percentage that's how I write out of
any percentage I out of 100 what do you give
this is how I like to write things koi I'm
gonna go 88 88 to 91. you know what I was
gonna say I was gonna say 89. yeah yeah 80
it's 91 somewhere in there but like definitely
in the in the near 90. yeah I think it's like
a perfect family film now let's compare our
rating to Rotten Tomatoes oh there's a fourth
one coming out oh [__] in 2024 we're not
oh there's a poster we can join oh it's in
March that's soon March 2024 oh my God 10
and a half months we should have waited but
now we can watch all of them before now we
can do it oh damn these all got good ratings
holy crap hey we were on the money though
look at that even Kung Fu Panda 2's out of
that 80s one percent that's rare for a sequel
87 87 yeah we were running the money there
higher than the audience score I mean that's
250 000 people yeah it is versus yeah that's
pretty solid Good Sense 250 000 people uh
2008 so this movie is uh what 17 years old
I feel like I've seen some of it I'm gonna
be really honest with you guys the kids movie
so I want to be a little bit careful here
and I've mentioned this in some other videos
from around I want to say 2008 to 2012. no
I go a little higher 2008 to like 2016. I
had a lot of I was primarily functioning morning
noon and night of a lot of flowers you know
what I mean so you had a different experience
there were some parts where I was like I had
to question like had I seen this but this
is familiar but I didn't know that that happens
to be quite a quite a lot where I'm like I
don't know if I've seen this or have I've
Just Seen imagery so I was working at a movie
theater until 2008 2009 and I was worried
I'd seen it because I was working at the theater
when this came out but I think it was on my
way out so I don't I didn't catch it I was
a little worried because I might have seen
like a minute or two like checking on someone
but like yeah had not seen this one like I
I watched Tucker and Dale vs Evil with Roxy
and I was like I know I saw this but I don't
remember anything First Watch I was just like
totally uh yeah there was a period where I
know I can honestly tell you like sometimes
I watch movie watch a movie on my own time
because I it was a bad experience of no there's
a reason I don't remember a lot what a gift
First Watch partner and I was like yep nope
taking it back none of this familiar to me
whatsoever like this is like a brand new experience
and that's what was happening here when I
was watching it too I was like I honestly
don't know if I've put this on before well
I want to watch the next one so yeah let's
do it I for sure definitely I don't I can't
I I've I don't think I've even glimpsed at
all what what happens 2011 I guess so yeah
I definitely wasn't I have not seen the next
one and 81 is pretty pretty reassuring for
a sequel all right sweet all right guys thanks
for being here koi thank you my friend ladies
and gentlemen we'll see you all soon thank
you to the sponsor of this video you know
that sponsor that one that one there foreign